the most important thing our youth
should look at nowadays is to decide
what they are going to do after high
school eighty-five percent of our high
school graduates want to go to college
of the University while the other 15 go
into various jobs but why don't we do it
the other way around why don't we try to
have eighty-five percent of our people
just like in Europe and in the States go
and get jobs get over this same culture
that we have I mean I've worked as a
waiter I've worked and cleaned in my
days my children have now we need people
to just go out and kill this an ambition
about the labor force we want people to
start working with their hands and then
move on